there's a problem here
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness while it's actually a really
great movie has several pretty
noticeable issues including certain
cameos unanswered questions and one big
glaring issue that a lot of marvel
movies have started to fall into but
before we get into it spoiler alert for
doctor strange 2 since we'll be going
over all the spoilers in the movie as
well as the pretty scary horror scenes
in the film but first let's start with
the movie's opening scene
[Music]
the first issue with the multiverse of
madness was the really cold opening
scene we got absolutely no introduction
to the characters on screen the
alternate defender strange in america
chavez while i usually like a cold open
like you might see in the office i don't
feel like this cold open was done very
well it was like it was simply there in
an effort to shorten the film's run time
leaving very little time for setting up
the plot of the film one thing i did
like about the beginning of the film was
at the reception for christine's wedding
when strange turned her water into wine
just like the story of jesus turning
water into wine during the wedding at
cana after the big monster battle though
we were sent right into wanda's
introduction to the film and dr
strange's first conversation with wanda
seemed really unnatural there were lots
of badly placed cuts in their
conversation making it seem like their
dialogue was just unrealistic kind of
like a soap opera or an old sitcom the
next issue lies in the character cameos
in the film professor xavier captain
carter reed richards and black bolt of
the multiversal illuminati were pretty
much wasted these actors and the
characters they portrayed had so much
potential to add to the movie but their
time in the film was cut really short by
wanda john krasinski as reed richards or
mr fantastic for instance had so much
potential to act as a leading character
in the movie but wanda just turned him
into rubber bands with the little
expecto patronum and ended his time in
the film while their cameos were
basically wasted i actually really
enjoyed their death scenes it was just
so unexpected that all of them would die
so quickly it reminded me of the
completely unexpected scene in the tv
show invincible where omniman killed all
the guardians of the globe also just
because they're dead in this universe it
doesn't mean we won't see them again in
an alternate universe so we may still
get to see john krasinski again in the
fantastic four the biggest issue with
the movie though lies in an issue that
we've started to see in a lot of marvel
films which is that we don't ever get a
grounded friendly neighborhood conflict
anymore instead we get world-ending
events global conflicts or alien
invasions and when that's not enough we
get multiversal threats and universe
ending events like in doctor strange 2.
i miss the times when we simply got to
see a guy build a metal suit in a cave
so he can escape
instead we get a crazy witch trying to
steal the powers from a girl who can
travel the multiverse so she can be with
their non-kid kids or destroy the
multiverse trying because the mcu has
been around for so long and is getting
so large they feel like they have to
constantly one-up whatever happened in
the last movie marvel needs to realize
that not every movie can be end game
they can't all have world ending events
and still make audiences feel a high
level of character investment because we
typically know that everything will turn
out okay in the end also it seemed like
they were trying to shove just too much
into one movie we were left with a lot
of unanswered questions such as where
did america chavez come from or where
did she get her powers and we also just
had the bomb dropped on us that our
dreams are visions into our multiversal
selves lives it just didn't make much
sense and it left us with more questions
than answers also what was up with
doctor strange's third eye my only guess
is that it's a symbol of cathon
possessing doctor strange after he used
the darkhold since cathon is the one who
created the darkhold and gave the
scarlet witch her powers lastly the
after credit scenes were a bit of a
letdown we got a short scene of clia one
of doctor strange's love interests in
the comics inviting strange to join her
on a multiversal adventure to save a
universe from an incursion we also got a
scene of pizza papa played by bruce
campbell who makes an appearance in
almost every sam raimi film finally
stopping hitting himself in the face
before telling the audience it's over i
hope that these end credit scenes would
further connect the movie to loki or
spiderman no way home since that was
where we got to see the beginning of the
fracture of the multiverse so it was a
bit disappointing to not get this
connection i will say though that the
multiverse of madness had a ton of
amazing qualities the first thing that
stood out to me was that it took on the
persona of a horror film the first of
its kind in the mcu it was given what i
would call the raimi effect and what
exactly do i mean by the raimi effect
sam raimi the director for doctor
strange 2 has a very particular style
for his films he's known for directing
the original spider-man trilogy and the
evil dead franchise so he's no stranger
to superhero or horror films and i feel
like this movie put together some of the
best aspects of both genres to make one
great film it was fun to see tropes from
both the horror genre as well as the
superhero genre all in one movie like
how wonder would attack the protagonist
through mirrors or how the faces in the
pictures would turn to look at you as
you walk by we also got a classic fourth
wall break from wanda similar to the
ones we got in one division also i love
how we got an exorcist inspired wanda
after she exited the mirror dimension it
was so twisted and strange pun intended
that it made my hair stand on end and of
course in evil dead fashion we had to
get a zombie in the movie another thing
that really stood out to me was the
inclusion of transitions that are
completely characteristic of sam raimi's
work like we saw in his spider-man
trilogy as well as a striking music
composition which usually accompanies
any raimi movie the film's composer
danny elfman is well known for his
unique compositions and he's worked with
sam raimi multiple times in the past the
electric guitar riffs and rock and roll
music mixed in with the classical score
really set the tone for the film as one
that's completely different from the
other mcu films the one scene in
particular where this was the most
evident was when doctor strange was
fighting one of his multiversal selves
in a crazy fun musical battle that ended
with the multiversal strange getting
impaled this scene while it had a pretty
morbid ending actually reminded me of
fantasia the 1940 animated musical
anthology film by walt disney
productions the way the music interacted
physically with the characters and their
surroundings perfectly encapsulated the
effects present in fantasia doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness has
to be the craziest marvel movie we've
gotten to date even superseding the
craziness of avengers end game and
infinity war although it had several
issues such as the wasted cameos
unanswered questions and the unnecessary
one-upsmanship marvel movies seemed to
have always trying to top the last
world-ending event doctor strange 2 was
still an absolutely amazing film and i
can't wait to see where the marvel
multiverse will take us next anyways
that's gonna be all for today if you
like what you saw check out the video on
your screen for some different content
or drop a comment below on something
else you'd like to see also don't forget
to like and subscribe as it truly does
help me out and thanks for watching
rocket riley